Traduttore: Federico Pepe
Revisore: Elena Montrasio
Sono emozionata come
in un primo giorno di scuola
perché per chi insegna
ogni giorno è come il primo
perché bisogna conquistarsi
le persone che si hanno davanti
e io con che diritto vi posso togliere
dieci minuti di oggi pomeriggio?
Solo perché spero di potervi
raccontare qualcosa
che possa avere un senso.
Parlando di scuola tutti
sono capaci di dire qualcosa
perché o uno insegna,
o ha la moglie che insegna
o ha un figlio che va a scuola,
o un nipote che va a scuola
e poi tutti siamo stati a scuola.
La diamo per scontata, la scuola
ma la scuola è un luogo
dove possono accadere delle cose belle
o delle cose talmente annoianti,
annoianti...
da convincere a cambiare rotta
magari a lasciare la scuola.
Che cosa può rendere le ore di scuola
delle ore affascinanti, interessanti
che aiutano a mettere a frutto
quel che ogni bambino, ogni ragazzo è,
perché ogni bambino e ogni ragazzo
possa prendere la strada della vita.
Perché queste ore
possano avere un senso,
per aprire un orizzonte.
Vorrei partire da un fatto
che mi ha colpito moltissimo.
Un bel po' di anni fa, una ragazza
nella stazione Termini si suicida
e lascia questo biglietto ai genitori:
Perdonatemi
mi avete dato tutto
mi avete dato il necessario, il superfluo
ma non l'indispensabile.
Ecco, io, da quel giorno
tutte le volte che ho guardato
in faccia degli adolescenti,
e poi, quando ho visto
crescere i miei figli
ho sempre avuto in mente quel biglietto.
Che cos'è l'indispensabile che serve
per valorizzare e godersi
il dono della vita?
Ma cosa c'entra questa domanda
così grande con la scuola?
Vi racconto un altro fatto.
Più o meno 15 anni fa,
una mia alunna, Tullia
che adesso è medico
e ortopedico, a 15 anni,
una ragazza piena di vita,
di quelle che rompono le scatole
perchè alzan sempre il braccio
e fanno sempre tante domande
chiede urgentemente un appuntamento
e mi viene a parlare,
si siede davanti a me
e coi suoi occhi acuti,
di quelli che ti penetrano
mi chiede: Prof, io ho fatto un conto
ho calcolato che ogni anno
io passo a scuola 1000 ore
che sono 30 ore la settimana,
33 settimane
sono più o meno 1000 ore
il pomeriggio, in media,
due ore e mezzo di studio
quindi, ogni anno,
io dedico alla scuola
più o meno 1500 ore
della mia vita
faccia una moltiplicazione:
tre anni di asilo,
cinque anni di elementari,
tre anni di medie,
cinque anni di liceo,
ma sono migliaia
e migliaia di ore della mia vita.
Se fossero ore da buttar via,
senza senso,
io perderei la mia vita, venendo qua.
Ma perché devo studiare?
Io non potevo non prendere
sul serio questa domanda
e le ho detto:
Cara Tullia scuola deriva da 'scholé'
che in greco vuol dire 'tempo libero'.
Tu non ci potrai credere
perché una volta erano pochi
i bambini e i ragazzi
che avevano la possibilità
di non lavorare e di dedicarsi allo studio
alla conoscenza, all'imparare.
Però, come tutti i doni,
occorre saperli valorizzare,
occorre capire che senso ha
un dono che ti viene fatto,
occorre scartarlo un dono
per capire che cosa c'è dentro
ecco qual è il senso
delle 1000 ore di scuola
che i nostri studenti fanno ogni anno.
Pensate che in Italia ci sono
7 milioni e mezzo di studenti
che ogni mattina varcano
le soglie delle scuole,
800.000 insegnanti
che stanno con loro,
sono miliardi di ore di vita
che dovrebbero essere piene di senso,
di quella scoperta,
questo è il cuore della scuola,
di quella scoperta di sé e della realtà,
del vero, del bene e del bello
che sono nascosti dentro il reale.
Dentro la scuola, passano tanti mondi:
lo scopo della scuola
non è studiare dei libri.
Attraverso le discipline,
la fisica, la matematica, la filosofia,
le scienze, l'italiano, noi entriamo
in rapporto con la realtà,
attraverso tutto quel patrimonio
di lavoro, di conoscenza
e di esperienza che altri
ci hanno regalato,
perché noi li possiamo reinventare,
noi insegnanti con i ragazzi.
Questo è il tono che dovrebbe
avere ogni ora di lezione,
è per questo che, all'inizio dell'anno,
ho deciso di portare tutti
i miei studenti a bordo del Voyager.
Avrei voluto farlo veramente,
ma era impossibile.
Troppo costoso.
E li ho semplicemente portati
in palestra a vedere
quel filmato straordinario
in cui gli astronauti vedono
in fondo allo spazio emergere,
come un piccolo puntino,
la Terra e la vedono sorgere
e loro, invece di prendere delle misure,
cominciano a dire - Che bello.
Ecco, questa domanda
- Che fai, tu, luna in cielo?
è la stessa domanda del pastore
del Canto notturno di Leopardi.
Questo è quello che ho voluto far capire
ai miei ragazzi anche quest'anno,
dentro alla scuola si entra
per aprirsi al mondo e alla realtà,
per scoprire sé.
E in questo rapporto
tra docente e studenti,
tra passato e presente
si costruisce il futuro.
Fisica in moto, il laboratorio
che 7 anni fa ho collaborato
a far aprire in Ducati,
che sfrutta l'attrattiva della moto
per spiegare il senso
delle leggi della fisica,
nasce da questa passione,
dalla passione di imprenditori,
di tecnici, di ingegneri, di insegnanti,
che sanno che non c'è niente
di più assurdo
che una risposta a una domanda
che non si pone.
Ogni giorno noi dobbiamo scommettere
sul fatto che davanti a noi
ci son dei ragazzi
che hanno questo desiderio
di vero, di bene, di bello,
di compimento, di felicità,
questo desiderio di capire,
anche se sepolto da mille detriti,
e studiare mille strade per farlo.
Lunedì scorso il 13 ottobre
in Ducati & Lamborghini abbiamo aperto
il quarto anno di Istituto Professionale
per ragazzi che avevano
smesso di andare a scuola.
Son 44 ragazzi che avevano
deciso di lasciare
e han deciso di ricominciare
ad andare a scuola,
facendo un percorso integrato
tra studio e lavoro.
Sapete cos'hanno scritto
nel post it che gli abbiamo
dato il primo giorno?
Un post it per scrivere
che cosa porti a questo progetto,
hanno scritto: curiosità,
passione, voglia di innovare,
stupore, voglia di collaborare,
responsabilità,
ed eran ragazzi che avevano lasciato,
che non lavoravano e che
non studiavano, i famosi Neet,
quelli che non sembra
più possibile raggiungere.
Ecco, è possibile raggiungere tutti,
perché esiste questo grande catalizzatore
che è il desiderio,
e noi è questo che dobbiamo accendere,
che dobbiamo incrociare
ed è la grande rivoluzione
che deve accadere a scuola
e può accadere senza nessuna legge,
perché da domani mattina
io posso andare a scuola,
con questo desiderio di scoprire
il vero, il bene e il bello
che c'è dentro la realtà,
insieme ai miei alunni,
insieme ai miei colleghi,
e questo è semplice,
è semplice come aprir la finestre
e guardare che c'è il cielo
(Applausi)